[Applause]
[Music]
NATO the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization the most important military
alliance in the world has just turned 70
this anniversary comes in the midst of
one of the most politically and
diplomatically significant crises that
it has suffered in its entire history
today on visual politic you and I will
get to know NATO just a little bit
better
[Music]
because this 2019 marks the anniversary
of NATO some of the visual politic team
traveled to Romania to learn more about
how this organization works it spoke to
some of the people in charge and to
witness native maneuvers live so don't
tell me that it's not a fitting way to
celebrate its 70th birthday
[Music]
and by the way this video is one of
three videos in which we're going to get
to know this institution a little bit
better today we're going to see how it
works how it's changed over the years
and the challenges that it faces for the
years ahead so without further ado let's
crack on shall we on April the 4th 1949
the Treaty of the North Atlantic was
signed which led to NATO most important
military alliance of all time has
already sent throughout these 70 years
the organization has changed a lot but
most significantly it's grown you see it
was originally an agreement between just
12 countries and today it's got no less
than 29 members the United States Canada
Turkey and 26 other European states
including several former members of the
Warsaw Pact which was the former
military alliance formed between the
Soviet Union and the Eastern Bloc
countries
[Music]
very soon the Republic of North
Macedonia will become the 30th member of
the organization folks we're talking
about an alliance that represents almost
1 billion people half of the world's
economic power and most of the world's
military spending
it's an organization with joint command
structures and troops that train
together to be able to respond to a
crisis in a coordinated manner
[Music]
this global defense alliance wields an
unprecedented amount of power so the 29
countries that currently constitute NATO
they have accumulated an annual military
spending of more than one trillion US
dollars that is almost 60% of all the
military spending that occurs in all
countries everywhere in the world but
hold on for just a moment despite having
most of the world's military spending
power and being bigger and more powerful
than ever before NATO isn't exactly
enjoying its golden era this is
something that we've already talked
about in several videos here on visual
politic well in this and two upcoming
videos we're going to explain what's
happening in town NATO has evolved over
the years and the threats that it faces
in its future let us start with a bit of
history shall we
[Applause]
the threat of the Red Army
the 1940s are about to ends the Second
World War ended just four years prior
[Music]
the greatest conflict of all time has
left tens of millions of victims of war
not only direct war deaths but countless
additional lives cut short due to
disease and the political brutality of
totalitarian ideologies the end of the
Second World War
and then the end of Nazism but at the
same time it also led to the emergence
of a new split that would not only
divide Europe but it would divide the
world and it would do it for decades yep
that's right the Cold War had begun at
that time the European continent it was
devastated it was economically shattered
and its armies were tattered and
demobilized however there was an
important difference between eastern and
western Europe on the one hand Eastern
Europe was under the Soviet Union's
control which maintained more than 5
million soldiers in the region camilli
years on the other hands the presence of
the US and UK troops on the continent
shrunk very quickly between 1945 and
1946 the contingents from these two
countries deployed in continental Europe
dropped from a 4.5 million soldiers in
less than 900,000 that is to say by the
end of the 40s the difference in favor
of the Soviet troops was 5 to 1 which
you know it's a pretty big difference
and not only that but at the time coin
ISM was an expanding political force it
was spreading to countries all around
the globe and of course Moscow was very
very certain that it was not going to
lose its grip on Europe on an example
well check this out
[Music]
in 1947 the Czech Republic accepted the
Marshall Plan but soon after it was
forced to renounce due to pressure from
Moscow only a year later in 1948 there
was a coup that placed the country
firmly under communist control in that
same year the Soviet Union carried out
the Berlin Blockade
meaning West Berlin had to be supplied
by a staggering airlift of 900 daily
flights for months on end anyway folks
these were the circumstances that
created real fear in Western Europe that
the Soviet troops they would advance and
occupy new countries such as the Federal
Republic of Germany or even the entire
continent it was for precisely this
reason that France the UK Belgium the
Netherlands and Luxembourg swiftly
agreed on a mutual defense clause in the
Brussels treaty this was done in 1948
the fearing that this wasn't enough
these countries quickly turned to the
United States the defense of Europe's
free countries it really had to be
ensured and that's how finally on April
the 4th 1949 12 countries France
Netherlands Belgium Luxembourg Denmark
the United Kingdom Norway Italy Iceland
Portugal Canada and the United States
signs the Treaty of Washington or the
North Atlantic Treaty that gave birth to
NATO
NATO's first secretary-general Lord
Ismay summed up the goal of the Alliance
as quote keeping the Soviet Union out
the Americans in and the Germans down
kai Weis research and outreach officer
of the Austrian economic center it was
precisely in this founding treaty that
the famous article 5 was established the
parties agreed that an armed attack
against one or more of them in Europe or
North America shall be considered an
attack against them all in other words a
very clear agreements all for one and
one for all we hope to create a shield
against aggression and the fear of
aggression a bulwark which will permit
us to get on with the real business of
government and society the business of
achieving a fuller and happier life for
all our citizens harry s truman
President of the United States of
America
[Music]
but it didn't stop there in 1952 Turkey
and Greece joined the alliance and three
years later in 1955 the German Federal
Republic joined as well and it was soon
after that that the Soviet Union the
Eastern Bloc countries except the
Yugoslavia created their own alliance
the Warsaw Pact this was an alliance
that unified the power of all of
Europe's socialist countries we're
talking about more than six million
soldiers 65,000 tanks 15,000 combat
aircraft 2,000 warships and nuclear
missiles that were distributed among the
Member States Europe it was divided to
great military alliances confronted each
other across a lion sketched on a map
okay so at this point you might be
wondering well what does NATO really
done how many missions how many
interventions have they led how has the
alliance changed well let's get into
that
[Music]
a decisive year
after the fall of the Berlin Wall and
the collapse of the Soviet Union NATO an
organization created to face the Soviet
threat did not decrease its activity on
the contrary it slowly began to have a
much more active role both inside and
outside Europe throughout this process
1999 was a key year
[Music]
in that year three new countries join
the Alliance Poland Hungary and the
Czech Republic remember that these three
countries had once belonged to the
Warsaw Pact and has therefore been seen
by native decades as enemy countries
they do not become from the world of
diplomacy in my previous incarnation it
was the professor of theoretical physics
and I know very well that motion is a
relative concept you move in relation to
something in that which is true for
Natural Sciences it's also true for
history in an organization has to move
according to the time it has to move
faster to the backdrop and let's suppose
that backdrop is history when history
moves very fast as it's taking place in
these years nobody says that we want to
be relevant they have to move faster
than history faster this backdrop if
they want to be relevant for the future
I like to say that all of you have made
this organization to adapt its rhythm
that probably none of the organization
that were born after the secondary world
ham stands
it was the beginning of a process that
over the years led NATO to include a
large number of Eastern Bloc countries
that had been under Soviet control
Latvia Lithuania Estonia Bulgaria
Romania even Albania this huge expansion
of NATO infuriated the Russian political
elites but gave the organization much
more strength while also aiding these
newly independent countries to
accelerate and consolidate their reforms
without fear of reprisals from Russia
but that folks it's still Nepal 1999 was
also the year when NATO carried out its
first major offensive it intervened in
former Yugoslavia to stop the ethnic
cleansing that the Serbian leader
Slobodan Milosevic's was carrying out
against the Kosovo Albania nation to
stop the Serbian government NATO carry
out heavy attacks against political and
military targets and everybody has to
look forward and to try not only to
reconstruct physically the country that
more on to the consulate
[Music]
folks NATO spirit had changed there was
no longer just a defensive organization
[Music]
as any given moment that was even
speculation of a possible terrestrial
invasion of Serbia with NATO troops and
you know what it's rumored that the then
Russian leader Boris Yeltsin was so
humiliated and enraged because NATO had
dared to include Eastern European
countries in his alliance but he even
threatened a third world war
if NATO's troops tried to occupy Serbia
Russia would respond I have warned NATO
the Americans and the Germans not to
push us into military action otherwise
there will certainly be a European war
and maybe a world war Boris Yeltsin
President of Russia in a way years later
in 2008 Moscow his threats became a
reality
George's approach by Mikhail Saakashvili
to the European Union and above all to
NATO led the Russian government's you
unleash a war against this country the
point folks is that in the last few
years we've seen NATO take a much more
active role in addition to their
continued expansion and the intervention
in Serbia NATO is also intervened in
Afghanistan Iraq and Libya
and this has led to a huge controversy
the current debate it goes something
like this
should NATO become an institution that
acts where needed to protect its member
states even if they aren't under direct
attack should it step in if human rights
are being seriously violated anywhere in
the world or should have been limited to
being exclusively a defensive alliance
that is limit itself to act only if a
member country is militarily attacked
in short does NATO make sense today as
it was originally intended
[Applause]
and be careful because the implications
of this debate are huge
after all we're talking about the future
of the world and the role of the most
important military alliance of all time
we're talking about a debate that is at
the forefront and that in recent times
has had the president of the United
States Donald Trump as its undisputed
protagonist he claims that NATO no
longer works that it doesn't make sense
that it obsolete
absolutely and number two the people
aren't paying their way it's obsolete
and we pay too much fun NATO we're gonna
have the people that aren't paying
they're gonna start paying it's absolute
they were getting ripped in NATO they
don't pay their bills they are
delinquent and this gives rise to
another question so far NATO has always
worked under the leadership of the
United States but could it still work
and have a future if the United States
steps down from its leadership position
even if the u.s. remained a member could
NATO be compatible with a new military
leadership structure
[Music]
this is a topic that we've already
talked about here on visual politic on
several occasions but we'll take a more
detailed look in a future video
[Music]
for now we can say that despite their
problems and their mistakes NATO has
certainly been a huge success
I mean Europe today enjoys an
environment of peace safety and
cooperation between countries I mean
it's kind of like a good gang of friends
and don't think that this was always the
case nothing could be further from the
truth
for centuries conflicts and Wars between
European nations were routine events and
even after the Second World War the
tension between the west and the East
had only flourished in many senses NATO
fulfilled its purpose perfectly even
though its member countries haven't
always gotten along and have had their
good and bad times like when France
withdrew from the joint military
structure not the Alliance in 1966
anyway folks that is the story of how
NATO was born grew and changed in a
future video we're going to examine what
the Alliance means today and what
threats it faces so I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos don't
forget to check out our friends at the
Rica's they're the media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine as they always do also
this channel is possible because if
patreon ends our patrons on that
platform like it always is please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you next time
[Music]